It is said that the only constant is
change and that is certainly true in the
world of technology. We have changes
that need to be made all the time on our
systems. For example, we get monthly
updates from Microsoft for updating and
upgrading software or patching
applications. Or you might get a request
to modify or update the rules that are
in your firewall or to modify the
configuration of a network switch. Every
time you make a change, there is a
chance that that change could cause more
problems to occur. This may be a
relatively minor issue that maybe nobody
even notices or it might be a major
problem that brings the network down and
causes downtime for everybody in the
organization.
Unfortunately, in many organizations,
the process of change management is
something that is either dismissed or
completely overlooked. And if everybody
in the organization is able to make any
change they'd like whenever they'd like,
there will certainly be downtime and
outages associated with those processes.
Change management brings a series of
very standard processes and procedures
whenever you need to make a change. This
includes how often this change will
occur, how long it takes to implement
this change, the process that will be
used for installing that change, and
procedures for rolling back if the
change doesn't work. If an organization
does not have a formal change management
process, then this can be very difficult
to implement. It's much easier to make
changes whenever you'd like instead of
going through a very standard set of
processes and procedures that tends to
extend the entire change management
process.
We certainly want to avoid any type of
downtime and that's a major objective of
having a change management process. But
we also need to make sure that everybody
knows when these changes are occurring.
If one part of the organization has
asked to make a change, but that change
affects a different part of the
organization, then there is obviously a
conflict. We also want to make sure that
there's no mistakes. There might be two
people making changes on the network and
those changes conflict with each other
and ultimately cause downtime or data
loss. To give you an idea of what a
standard change management process might
look like, you start with the change
management request itself. Someone may
need you to upgrade some software. There
might be a requirement to change a
firewall configuration or you might have
received the latest monthly patches from
Microsoft and you need to deploy those
patches on your network. This purpose
for the change is put into the change
process so that everyone knows why
you're going through the process of
making these changes. You also need to
identify what the scope of this change
might be. If you're modifying software
that's only used by three people in the
organization, then the scope is
relatively small. But if you're
upgrading software that is used in the
core switch in your data center, you may
be affecting everybody in the
organization. This change management
process also determines when this change
will be made. This way, everybody in the
organization has this change on their
calendar and they know exactly what is
expected during that time frame. The
change request form commonly describes
what devices will be affected by this
change and the potential impact for
making this change in the organization.
If we're applying the latest set of
Microsoft patches, then the affected
systems would be every Windows device or
every Windows server in the organization
and the impact of this might be to close
potential security holes and perhaps
there are additional features or
enhancements that may be included as
part of these patches. The folks in your
organization in charge of this change
management process will evaluate any
risks associated with this change. If
you're making a change to your core
router, for example, there might be a
significant risk and we need to
understand what those risks might be so
that we can better understand how to
manage this particular change. There's
very often a change control board that
looks over all of this information and
determines if this change can proceed.
In some organizations, this change may
be pushed off until a different time
frame. For example, if you're in a
retail environment, you may not be able
to make changes during the holiday
season. But after the first of the year,
these changes may be easily implemented.
And after making the change, there's
still the final step of having the
enduser approve that the change was
successful. This way, you're able to get
feedback from the user saying that they
have tested your change and everything
is working as expected.
One thing you should always plan for is
a situation where you have implemented a
change, it did not work the way you
expected and you somehow need to bring
everything back to the way you started.
We refer to this as a roll back plan.
The roll back plan is a set of processes
and procedures that tell someone how to
get back to the original configuration
if everything goes wrong. In some cases,
this might be a very simple process. If
this is on a virtual machine, for
example, you simply need to roll back to
a previous snapshot and you're back up
and running in the original
configuration. But if this is a firmware
upgrade, it might be difficult and
sometimes impossible to revert back to a
previous firmware version. This means
that your rollback plan may not be to
install the old software. It may be to
swap out that equipment with one running
the older firmware. And of course, you
should always always have a backup of
this system. That way, if something does
go wrong, you can simply restore from
the backup and everything is exactly the
way it was before you started.
Another way to approach problems during
this change process is to have a backup
plan. This is a series of steps you can
follow if your original plan does not go
the way you were expecting. For example,
let's say that you're going to install a
software update on an existing firewall.
This process should take these steps.
You should connect to the web-based
management front end of the firewall.
Click the update button. Wait for the
download to complete. Press the reset
button to restart the firewall. And then
test the firewall settings with the new
software in place. The problem, however,
is if something goes wrong in any of
these steps. What is the alternate plan
if you run into issues during that
change process? Here's an example of the
things that could go wrong during that
firewall upgrade. The internet might be
down, so it's not able to download the
updated code. Maybe the browser that
you're using is not properly
interpreting the page that's used for
management on that firewall. Maybe the
download is starting, but it's failing
halfway through the download, or once
it's downloaded, the update file isn't
being validated properly by the software
inside of the firewall. All of these
problems are things that should have
been thought about prior to starting
this update process and there should be
a secondary process in place so that you
can get around these issues. So if we
run into these problems, what's your
plan B? And if there's a problem with
plan B, what's your plan C? And so on.
For example, maybe you thought
beforehand that the internet could be an
issue. So instead of relying on that
internet connection, you download the
file prior to the change so you have a
copy locally that you can install. Maybe
you put it on a flash drive to make it
easy to plug into the firewall and
install that change. Maybe you upload it
via TFTP on the management interface of
the firewall itself. Or perhaps you use
the firewall's command line console to
perform the upgrade. All of these are
useful backup plans and you should
consider all of these prior to the
change date. It can be difficult
sometime to make a reasoned decision
when you're in the heat of the moment.
So instead of having all of this occur
and try to make changes in real time,
you should think about where things can
go wrong and then come up with different
plans in case that issue occurs.
Let's say the change that you're working
on is upgrading the software in your
core switch in the middle of your data
center. This is the switch that everyone
in your organization relies on to be
able to access the internet and all of
the primary resources in the core of
your network. This would obviously be a
relatively risky change. So, what you
might want to do is perform plenty of
testing before implementing that
software. You would commonly do this in
a sandbox. This is a self-contained
system where you can make any changes
you like and it has no effect on the
uptime and availability of any of your
systems. So you might have a separate
core switch that you use just for
testing. You put that into your sandbox
environment and you start doing the
upgrade and applying the patches you
need to bring that software up to the
latest version. Once that upgrade is
done, you can now start testing that
software to see if it's performing as
you would expect. Normally there would
be a list of tasks that you can try and
confirm that that software is working
without any problem. And once you've
gone through this process, you can feel
relatively secure that the upgrade is
going to work as expected. This would
also be a good place to test your roll
back plan. You could install the new
software on the switch, pretend that
there's some type of problem with the
software, and then see if you can
install the older version of the
software to bring everything back to the
way it was originally. This whole time
you're performing all of these functions
in a sandbox and you don't have to worry
about bringing down any part of the
network or causing any disconnection for
your users.
The change management process involves a
number of different people across many
parts of the organization. Obviously,
the IT department will be involved for
the technical part of this change.
They're the ones that manage the
software, the operating systems, and the
applications that are running in your
technical environment. will also need
support from the business customer. This
is the person who is using the software.
It is responsible for upgrading the
code, but the actual day-to-day use of
that software will be done by your user
community. And there's usually a sponsor
associated with this change. This is
usually part of the organization that is
using the software or it may be the part
of the organization that is using their
budget to pay for this particular
change. This is very often three
different parts of the organization. So
we have to make sure that the
communication channels are open and that
everybody is aware of the change
management process.
Like any good set of processes and
procedures, we need a form to be able to
implement this change management
process. This change request form is
usually an online system where we can
put all of this information in and
submit it to the change management
board. Having a standardized form or a
standardized process in place ensures
that we're not missing anything. We know
exactly what the risks are. We know who
will be affected by this change. We know
technically what will be required and we
have information that describes the roll
back process. This also allows the
change management team to get detailed
reports so they can see how well or how
badly the change management process is
working for the company. This is usually
a very transparent process. It's very
common to have everyone in the
organization aware of the changes that
are going to take place and to have a
way that they can monitor these changes
as they are occurring.
The change management process starts
with one question which is why is this
change taking place. We need to
understand the reasoning behind making
this change so that all of the rest of
the processes down the line understand
the purpose for going through this
process. For example, this change may be
part of an application upgrade. And as
part of the application upgrade, there
are a number of new features that this
department has been waiting for for a
very long time. Also, as part of this
upgrade are series of bug fixes that
resolve a number of issues that they
currently have open. And in some cases,
these application upgrades might provide
you with performance enhancements. So,
not only are they getting newer features
and taking care of a number of bugs,
they may find that the application works
better than it ever has. We've already
talked about Microsoft's monthly
security patches and that is a very good
reason to have a change control process
because you want to make sure that all
of your systems remain as secure as
possible. Every change we make is going
to have some cost associated with it.
And this is why the very first part of
this change management process is
understanding why we're doing this so
that we can financially justify this
change.
From a technical perspective, we may not
always consider what the scope of the
change might be. We may have been tasked
with upgrading software that's on a
server. We perform the upgrade, we
restart the server, and we're done. But
did this change affect just people
connecting to that server, or did that
change affect a large part of your
infrastructure? A single change to a
firewall rule could affect multiple
applications that people are using. It
could affect internet connectivity for
one or more people in your company.
People connecting from a remote site may
find that they're no longer able to
connect to the resources they need. And
you might have external customers that
have lost access to a particular
resource. All of these things could
happen simultaneously just by changing a
single rule in a corporate firewall. We
also need to understand when this change
will occur. Is this something that we
can do during a normal workday or will
we need to do this change during a time
where the network is rarely used? Many
companies will have redundant systems
which allow them to make these changes
without having any impact to the user
community. Or this change may have an
impact on a core piece of equipment and
may have hours of downtime just to make
the single change.
Not every change is the same as every
other change. For example, you might
have a standard change. This is often a
lowrisk change to the organization. It's
something where you probably don't even
have to go through a formal change
management process because it is a
change that is already pre-approved.
This is something that happens all the
time. It's a well doumented change and
it's something that has a very low risk
of causing problems. For example, if you
need to replace a monitor on a user's
desk because the monitor is no longer
working, that is a change that has very
little risk to anyone else in the
organization and it's something that you
can easily replace without involving the
change management team. A normal change
might be something that's more of a
medium risk. It's not an urgent change,
but we still need to go through the full
change management process. For example,
if we need to update a rule in a
firewall or upgrade a database software
engine or replace a switch in the core
of our network, that goes through the
normal change management process. And
there will be times when you need to
make an emergency change. This may be a
high-risk change because you may not
have time to do all of the testing that
you would normally perform. An example
of an emergency change may be the
announcement of a zeroday vulnerability
that could affect your primary web
server. You might need to get a patch
for that web server as quickly as
possible and install it immediately on
the corporate web server. This type of
change does commonly involve the change
management board, but it's one that is
set to a much higher priority and very
often is implemented without any type of
delay.
The change management board will often
determine the best time frame to be able
to make that particular change. The
change is usually assigned to one of
many maintenance windows that have
already been preapproved by the
organization. Or this might be an
ondemand change. It might be a date and
time that's not part of a standard
maintenance window. So, we pick a
specific date and a specific time for
this particular change. Some
organizations have a regularly scheduled
downtime, usually Sunday mornings at
2:00 a.m. If there are changes to occur,
that's when the change will take place.
If there are no changes, then we skip
that downtime this week. And you may
find that your organization has certain
times in the year where there is a
change freeze. That means that you're
not allowed to make any changes at all
unless it is an emergency change to the
infrastructure. This might be a block of
time that's already preset. For example,
if you're in retail, you might have a
change freeze every year between
November 15th through January the 5th.
It might take a little bit of thought to
really determine what the impact of any
particular change might be. For example,
if you're upgrading firewall software,
you'll need to reboot that firewall
after installing the new software
version. You may think that that only
affects the firewall itself, but of
course, everybody in the organization
uses that firewall to communicate with
the internet. So, while you're making
that change, you could be affecting
everybody in the organization. Or this
change might affect a very small number
of people in the organization. For
example, you might be upgrading software
that is only used by two or three people
in the company, and when you make that
change, they're the only ones who could
ever be affected by anything associated
with that update. Sometimes it's
difficult to really understand what the
scope of a change might be. Let's say
you've been asked to upgrade the
software on a database server. Which
applications are using that database
server? If you don't have very good
documentation, it might take a little
bit of work to determine which
applications are connecting and using
the data stored on that device. Or let's
say you've been tasked with upgrading
every database server in the company.
But what if it's a database server
that's still powered on and running, but
nobody is using any part of that server?
No one's connected to that device in a
month. And therefore, you might need to
understand that the scope of that change
may be very different for that
particular server. When you're filling
out your change management form, it will
certainly ask what the affected systems
might be and what the impact of making
that change could possibly be. You need
to understand the complete impact of
making this particular change so that
the change management committee can make
the best possible decision.
There's very often a risk level
associated with any change you're making
in the organization. This might be a
relatively low risk change that affects
very few people or it may be a very
high-risisk change that could affect
everybody in the company. For example,
let's say that you've been asked to
implement a patch for problems that are
occurring on a server, but when you
install that patch, you find out that
the fix doesn't actually fix anything in
the software. Or maybe you find that the
patch that you've installed breaks
something else in that software, and now
you have to go through the entire
process again with this new problem. Or
maybe you find that implementing the fix
causes a problem with the underlying
operating system, and now the computer
won't boot. Or maybe everything is
working great. You put the fix on the
system, the patch doesn't break anything
else. Your computer reboots exactly the
way you would expect, but then all of
the data associated with that
application is now no longer accessible.
All of these things could potentially
happen just by installing a patch to an
existing application. Now, we need to
look at the other side of the coin and
understand what the risk might be for
not making this change. Perhaps
installing this patch would solve a
number of connectivity and availability
problems for the application. So not
making the change would mean that the
application continues to have these
problems. Or it could be that this patch
is necessary to communicate properly
with other devices and not making this
change could cause downtime to those
other services.
So now that you've put together all the
work to create that change control plan,
you can now present it to the change
control board. They will be responsible
for determining if that change takes
place or not. This very often includes
every department in the company so that
everyone understands what changes are
taking place and what the effects of
those changes might be. And you may find
that the change that you're trying to
implement does not have the priority it
needs to get done quickly. There may be
a number of other changes with a higher
priority that take precedence over
yours. So, it might take quite a bit of
time for the change control board to
schedule your change and put it on the
calendar. But now that the change
control board has given their approval,
it's up to you to make sure that the
change happens.
Most of the time, we're not putting
these plans together in some type of
vacuum where only we know what's going
on. Very often, we're interacting with
other parts of the IT department and
professionals who have gone through this
process before. For example, if we're
upgrading a firewall, we may want to
talk with people who are experts in that
firewall and that have gone through this
upgrade process before. They might give
you some ideas of what other backup
plans you might want to have ready to
go, and they might also give you some
ideas of how viable a roll back plan
might be for this particular change. The
goal is to make this process go as
easily and efficiently as possible. So
talking with other experts can give you
the information you need to make sure
that you've covered every possible
scenario.
And of course, no change is complete
until the users test the change and that
they're happy with the results. Often
these changes are not only for the IT
department. We might be updating some
accounting software that's important to
use for the ongoing operation of the
company. If we do our job properly, that
software will be updated and they'll be
very happy with the results. We tend to
talk about the end-user acceptance
process as the last bit of the process
that the users are finally getting
involved with, but in reality, they've
been involved with this entire change
management process from the very
beginning. They're the ones that needed
the software updated. They've worked
with you to make sure that you're able
to test that software, and ultimately,
they will be the ones to determine if
the software upgrade was a success.